♪ ♪
>> Dagen: SOME REPUBLICANS ARE
SHUNNING THE PARTISAN PRESS
AFTER YEARS OF ABUSE BUT NOW THE
LIBERAL MEDIA IS BEGGING THEM TO
COME TALK.
FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS
IS CALLING OUT "THE VIEW" AFTER
THE LIBERAL LADIES ASKED HIM TO,
THE SHOW.
DeSANTIS' TEAM RESPONDED TO
THE REQUEST WITH A LIST OF
DIRECT PERSONAL ATTACKS FROM THE
WOKE HOSTS.
HERE ARE SOME EXAMPLES.
>> YOU ARE JUST SHORT OF CALLING
HIM A NEGLIGENT HOMICIDAL
SOCIOPATH BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT HE
IS.
HE IS RISKING THE LIVES OF
CHILDREN.
PARENTS.
GRANDPARENTS, ANYONE THEY MAY
COME IN CONTACT WITH SO HE CAN
APPEAL TO HIS WHITE SUPREMACIST
BASE.
>> I THINK HE IS A FASCIST END
OF BIGOT.
>> IT'S ANTI-BLACK, ANTI-GAY,
ANTI-LGBTQ+.
>> ANTI-AMERICAN.
>> STARTED WITH CRT.
SPEAKERS START COMING AFTER
BLACK PEOPLE, WHAT COMES NEXT?
LGBTQ+, WOMEN, OTHER
MARGINALIZED PEOPLE.
>> Dagen: OTHER REPUBLICANS
DITCHING THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
AHEAD OF THE MAINSTREAM AND
OUTLETS LIKE "POLITICO" ARE
MOCKING THEM CLAIMING THEY ARE
MAKING A BIG MISTAKE.
DeSANTIS SAYS NYET TO
"THE VIEW."
>> Greg: IF YOU ARE GOING TO
SAY SOMEBODY IS EVIL THAT MEANS
YOU CAN NEVER TALK TO THEM.
COMPARED TO WHAT WE DID IN THE
A BLOCK.
NONE OF US AGREE WITH AOC BUT WE
ACTUALLY WERE TALKING SERIOUSLY
ABOUT HER.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT DISTINCTION.
THE RIGHT BELIEVES THE LEFT IS
WRONG BUT THE LEFT BELIEVES THE
RIGHT IS EVIL.
SO OLD KRAUTHAMMER LINE.
WHY DO YOU, MICHELLE?
YOU SAY THAT I AM WORSE THAN
HITLER.
THEY ARE MISERABLE.
YOU DO FOX.
YOU HAVE A GOOD TIME.
PEOPLE ARE NICE AND FUN.
WHEN HAROLD OR JESSICA GETS
DESTROYED BY ME ON THE SHOW WE
STILL HAVE SO MUCH FUN IN THE
BREAK.
>> Harold: FUN AT DINNER TOO.
>> Greg: WE GET A LITTLE
LOADED.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER THAT.
LET'S SAY YOU'RE AT THE AIRPORT
AND YOU'RE FORCED TO WATCH MSNBC
OR CNN.
YOU WONDER WHO DIED.
IT IS THEIR RATINGS.
THE PROBLEM WITH LEGACY MEDIA IS
THAT THEY ARE STILL IN THEIR
SHELL AND WHEN SOMEONE OUTSIDE
THEIR SHELL JOINS THEM IT
CREATES MELTDOWNS AND IT'S VERY
PERSONAL.
IT'S VERY PERSONAL TO THEM ON
"THE VIEW" WHEN THEY RUN INTO
SOMETHING AND HERE IT'S NEVER
UNPLEASANT BECAUSE WE DON'T TAKE
IT PERSONALLY.
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
REPUBLICANS AND THE HARD LEFT.
>> Dagen: JESSICA HAS LET ME
PLAY WITH AND HOLD HER CHILD.
YOU WOULD NEVER.
JESSE, I HAVEN'T EVEN MET THE
KID.
WANT TO BABYSIT TONIGHT?
>> Katie: DeSANTIS IS MARKED
ON THE REASON WHY HE'S BEEN SO
SUCCESSFUL PROMOTING HIS
POLICIES IS BECAUSE HE DOESN'T
TAKE THE BAIT ON OFFERS LIKE
THIS.
THE VIEW IS NOT INTERESTED IN
HAVING A REAL SERIOUS
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT HE'S
BEEN DOING IN FLORIDA.
THEY KNOW HE MAY BE A 2024
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE OR
PROBABLY WHY THEY ARE TRYING TO
GET HIM ON EARLY.
IF THEY REALLY BELIEVE THE
THINGS THEY SAID ABOUT HIM.
HE'S A HOMICIDAL SOCIOPATH,
BIGOT, WHY WOULD YOU GIVE HIM A
PLATFORM TO CONTINUE SAYING
THOSE THINGS?
DeSANTIS AND HIS TEAM KNOW
THAT THEY ARE TRYING TO USE HIM
FOR GAMES AND THEY ARE NOT USING
-- THEY ARE NOT PLAYING THE GAME
ANYMORE.
96% OF THE PRESS IDENTIFIES AS
LEFTIST OR LIBERAL AND IT'S TIME
TO GIVE THEM A FAIR SHOT.
IF THAT MEANS IGNORING THEIR
MEDIA OUTLETS THEY DON'T NEED TO
GET THEIR MESSAGE OUT, THEN THEY
CAN GO AROUND IT.
IT'S A SHAME FOR PEOPLE WATCHING
BUT ALL THEY ARE ASKING FOR IS A
LITTLE BIT OF FAIRNESS AND MAYBE
EVENTUALLY DOWN THE ROAD.
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE FOREVER.
MAY BE JUST A LITTLE REMINDER OF
HOW TO HAVE A DECENT, CIVIL
CONVERSATION ABOUT SERIOUS
ISSUES BASED ON THE FACTS WHICH
"THE VIEW" TENDS TO NOT BE
INTERESTED IN PURSUING.
>> Dagen: SAYING THAT
DeSANTIS WENT ON "THE VIEW" HE
IS ALSO SUBJECTING HIS
SUPPORTERS TO THE SHRILL TORTURE
THAT YOU HAVE TO LISTEN TO.
THE ORAL TORTURE.
>> Jesse: IF HE DID DO THE
VIEW, IT WOULD BE HARD FOR THEM
TO GET A WORD AND BECAUSE YOU
HAVE THESE WOMEN YELLING AND
SCREAMING AT HIM THE WHOLE TIME
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE UPSIDE
WOULD BE FOR HIM.
RIGHT NOW THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
NEEDS REPUBLICANS ON THE SHOWS
BECAUSE THE SHOWS ARE BORING AND
NO ONE'S WATCHING THE SHOW SO
ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU NEED US TO
COME ON YOUR SHOWS TO MAKE YOUR
SHOWS INTERESTING SO YOU CAN GET
A GOOD RATING, SORRY.
YOU CALLED ME A MURDERER DURING
COVID, CALLED ME A TRAITOR.
THE OTHER DAYS OF THE WEEK YOU
CALL ME RACIST AND YOU ARE
WORKING WITH POLITICAL
PROSECUTORS TO PUT ME IN PRISON.
WOULD ANY OF US DO WELL IN
PRISON?
NO.
HAVE YOU SEEN THESE REPUBLICAN
SENATORS, THEY WOULDN'T LAST A
SINGLE DAY.
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THEY ARE WORKING IN TANDEM WITH
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY SO I'M NOT
GOING TO BE YOUR TACKLING DUMMY
FOR A RATING.
AND THEY'RE NOT DOING POLITICAL
JOURNALISM.
WE HAD A SOURCE THAT PRESENTED A
GREAT SCOOP THAT MIGHT BRING
DOWN A DEMOCRAT AND MIGHT AFFECT
THE POLITICAL CAMPAIGN AND YOU
HANDED TO HIM, TIED UP IN A NICE
BOW, THE NETWORKS WOULDN'T EVEN
LOOK AT IT.
THEY WOULD SUPPRESS THAT STORY.
THEY ARE NOT ACTUALLY DOING
JOURNALISM.
THEY ARE DOING PARTISAN
PROPAGANDA.
FOX NOW WAS SUCH A HUGE PLATFORM
AND IF YOU HAVE THE INTERNET AND
PODCASTS, YOU DON'T NEED TO DO
THESE OTHER NETWORKS.
YOU DON'T NEED TO ANSWER
ANYTHING FROM THESE GUYS.
YOU KNOW IF THE AGENDA IS.
YOU GET MUCH BIGGER AUDIENCE
WITH THE WAY THINGS ARE HERE.
>> Dagen: TAKING NOTES, LOOK
OUT.
>> Harold: IS SHORTSIGHTED AND
SMALL MINDED OF POLITICIANS TO
NOT STAND IN THE PROVERBIAL
KITCHEN AND TAKE ANY HEAT.
IF THEY HAVE SAID THINGS ABOUT
HIM.
IF SOMEONE CALLED ME A FASCIST
AND A RACIST AND ANTI-SEMITE I
WOULD WANT TO GO ON THIS SHOW
AND SAM NOT.
>> Jesse: I DON'T WANT THE
LINE OUT THERE ON TELEVISION,
I'M NOT A RACIST.
WELL, I JUST GAVE IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
>> Harold: I DON'T THINK
THAT'S ALL THEY WOULD ASK.
BUT I THINK IT'S A PATHETIC
EXAMPLE OF WHAT POLITICS HAS
BECOME.
HERE'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO.
THE COUNTRY WANTS LEADERS WHO
UNITE.
THEY WANT LEADERS WHO CAN LISTEN
TO EACH SIDE AND EXPRESS
THEMSELVES.
IF THE OTHER SIDE IS OUTRAGEOUS
IN THEIR CONVERSATION, LOOK THE
COUNTRY BE THE JUDGE OF THAT.
I DON'T KNOW RON DeSANTIS.
I HAVE READ ABOUT HIM AND HEARD
ABOUT HIM.
IMPRESSIVE RESUME.
THIS IS A MARK AGAINST HIM IN MY
BOOK.
IF YOU CAN'T TAKE THE TOUGH
QUESTIONS FROM "THE VIEW," YOU
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T BE PRESIDENT.
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE TO HAVE
STANDARDS AND DO CLASSY SHOWS.
>> Harold: YOU CAN DO PRIME
TIME.
>> Jesse: I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT PRIME TIME.
MEET THE PRESS, THE SUNDAY
MORNING SHOWS.
>> Dagen: DO YOU WANT A FINAL
WORD?
>> Greg: I AM GOOD.
I AM THINKING ABOUT WHAT I'M
GOING TO EAT.
I HAD BRISKET FOR LUNCH.
>> Harold: MY EXPRESSION MADE
YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO EAT.
>> Greg: IT'S 5:30.